reed detmers will be the angel's
starting pitcher today his major league
debut he's a guy the angels drafted
just a little over 12 months ago and
he's in the big leagues for the very
first time
today out to center
[Applause]
one down now martay pitch and that one
didn't miss by much on a 3-2
and that'll end up being a walk now
olson
arte going and the throw it hit marte
and rolls into shallow left center field
martay
well he was picked off but he was going
on the play and make it difficult for
the first baseman
and his throw toward second big jump
martay's running in a swing and a miss
olson strikes out martay has a couple of
stolen bases he's at third this is your
first major league strikeout against an
all-star in matt olsen that'll be
something you'll remember the rest of
your life and here comes lowry got him
the kid is all right
struck him out
and that is how the inning will end so
detmer's prevents
marte from coming in and here's the uh
second major league start the first this
year the kid from cal and central valley
product dalton jeffries is here in
triple a in vegas and 12 stars three and
one to five one nine era he watched the
first battery faces in his second major
league start that'll bring up otani
pitch to ohtani
county hits a high fly ball shallow
cannon coming in and kind of grabs it
justin upton will be the next batter 2-2
pitch to upton and that's a swing and a
miss fastball running in on upton david
fincher's at first two out bottom of the
first stassi now
stassi drives it right center field
after it is martay at the wall
gone
two-run shot
and a two-nothing lead
entertaining his scone the other way
right center that is his power
[Applause]
and harrison the batters
3-2 pitch
is dropped into left field for a base
hit in front of upton and the a's have
their lead off man aboard so our first
look at john gomes in these uniforms and
he pops this one up left side of the
infield
jose iglesias now on the outfield grass
makes the catch that'll bring up josh
harrison there's a line shot in the
right that's gathered in by adam eaton
ball is hit sharply by harrison marsh
takes a pitch that misses and he draws a
one-out walk and the next batter for the
angels will be jack mayfield who's
hitting out of the eight hole today
mayfield line drive that's a base hit
and into the courier marsh can run
headed for third cannot for the ball
he will send him
and he scores the captain
third base coach
he saw canada having a tough time and
not get behind the baseball as far as
getting to throw into the cut-off man
and he did not hesitate so a two-strike
opposite-field single for martay and the
aids are in business runners at the
corners for matt olson
olson hits one high and deep right
center field and that baby is gone this
game is tied this is living too long in
the same area cold matt olson just
leaving the yard so a huge hit for the
a's and what a surprise it belongs to
matt olsen and a walk to laureano brings
john gomes to the plate
john gomes and that one's hit high and
deep down the third base line and that
one is gone john gomes in his oakland
debut with a massive drive to left
scores ramon laureano it's a 5-3 oakland
lead how about making an entrance in the
green and gold for yon gomes and now
mars who walked and scored in the second
strike three called and that's a
beautiful pitch by dalton jeffries a
little two-seamer with some action
coming back now mayfield he doubled in a
run swing and a missing chase the hard
breaking ball off the plate strong one
two three inning for dalton jeffries
getting better as the game rolls along
it's a map hit by it and that'll bring
up lowry who's struck out and bounced
out
and that's a base hit to center field so
two on and one out for the athletics and
that's going to be it for reed detmers
that burst debut ends in the fifth with
runners at first and second new pictures
austin warren lowry's at second and
lauriano's at first and two away john
gomes will be the next batter
rips this one to right field and that's
a base hit
here comes lowry eaton's throw to the
plate is cut off lowry scores with a
slide and it's six to three john gomes
comes through so one away shohei ohtani
will be the better as the angels bat
here in the bottom of the fifth
ohtani
hits it toward harrison fires to chapman
on the first double play
and these get a four five three double
play to finish off
the bottom of the fifth and this is the
mother of dalton jeffries and that was
after the four five three double played
in the bottom of the fifth
and to say she was psyched well that
would be an understatement so lowry will
hit with the bases loaded and a chance
for these to bust it open
and there's a line drive and that is
short hopped by upton one run scores
two runs are gonna score and it's eight
to three lowry comes through again face
hit to left by lowry and the a's get a
cushion big time in the sixth eight
three ball game top of the seventh
ground ball heist has it spins nice play
and garrett is there popping up quickly
to make the flip over to first base for
that dice over to junior garrett pretty
out and they have runner over there at
first base
garrett can't get it
mayfield can that's a nice play
jab on that bare hand by jack mayfield
especially with andrews going down the
line who still runs pretty well once
again i thought there was no chance
fletcher fletcher's at first so here's
ohtani a left-handed hitter he's all for
three and that's swung on in the ground
one on the right side harrison goes to
chapman he goes to first and he is get
the double play
and he is double up otani for the second
time today so bottom of the ninth he is
with an eight to three lead and it'll be
sergio romo
and that's a swing and a miss
a change up at 81 miles an hour and you
see it really kind of dove away from
that dice two out and that'll bring up
iglesias swung on a miss on a slider
away dalton jeffries as the asb the
angels 8-3 and the kid making his first
appearance of the year gets his first
major league win